Good morning, Paul.
Hey, Ivan, I wanted to let you know, oh, Chris is here already too. I think we're, Chris and I are hopping to a other call, but we should have Lewis or someone in here, right Chris?
Yeah, there should be.
Yeah, no problem. Thank you for the update. So, we'll wait.
No problem if.
Shoot me an email if you don't get anyone else.
Sure, sure. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you, Kris. Thank you.
Thank you, bye.
OK.
Murray, loose.
Good morning!
Good to see you.
You too, sir. How you been? I know you were off, uh, what, a week ago or whatnot? How'd that go? Everything went okay?
Yeah, I was out for my bedding anniversary. I was traveling Thailand for a few days with family, so a great time.
Oh, nice. Yeah, I just had my wedding anniversary as well on Tuesday, but I didn't travel to Thailand, Mr. Fancy.
Yeah, my wife wants one international trip in the entire year, no matter what you do, but she need to be go. So my kids, like I have a five-year daughter, so school is off nowadays, so summer vacation. So yeah, it's good, good fun, spend good time.
Mm.
OK.
That's good. That's good. I'm glad you got a chance to go to Thailand and enjoy that. I mean, I have to go over a lot of water before I can get to Thailand, you know, to that degree. But yeah, we're stuck over here in the United States and it's not as great as Thailand or any other place over there.
I stay for two days Thailand, then three days Phuket, and yeah, one day I think Karabi, yeah, so almost a week.
Okay, do you all take like a train or do you just fly over there?
No, fly, fly, fly over.
Okay.
That's good.
So, all together, it's different country altogether.
Yeah, yeah, I definitely. I mean, even though the world looks at, you know, India and everywhere else as all of Asia, yeah, it's definitely different if you go from like Korea, Japan, Thailand, you know, whatever, and you're like, yeah, you can call it Asia, but they are different.
Mm.
One, yeah.
Yeah, that's right, true. Everything culture, weather, everything very different.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. I myself was born in South Korea. And yeah, when I was over there growing up, I went to different areas from like Japan and South Korea and China and things like that. It was just like, I mean, even Philippines and Vietnam, it was really different culture wise. Everything was totally different.
Okay.
Yeah, right.
I think Paul and Kris joined for a while, but they mentioned that they're going to jump on a different call. So.
Okay, okay.
Linden is going to join or he is out. He's out, I think, or he's in today.
Uhh...
Linden is out sick today. Tim might join to that degree. I mean, honestly, I guess at this point we could just expect just me today.
Yeah, I think yesterday Mayor Lee is another meeting, Amit too.
Ohh, wow, I guess we could just talk about it.
So, only where the only audience today?
OK, alright. Well, I mean, the there's a really only as far as from my side, there was only one thing that we noticed that occurred, and...
At first, we didn't realize it because we noticed that Linden, Linden was off Monday, this past Monday. He went to a different state. But the point was, is prior to that, he wasn't off on Mondays, you know, as far as vacations or anything, he would come in on his Mondays, do his thing.
Yeah.
Right.
And he comes in at 7 in the morning. And with that said, we this Monday passed and so we noticed because Linden wasn't in, we took a look at the board as far as the tickets and we noticed that there was a lot of tickets that were created over the weekend, Saturday and Sunday.
It was during morning shift, second shift and third shift, mainly it was morning, first and second shift to that. And we noticed that they weren't worked on or touched, they carried over into Monday. And when Tuesday came around, we
Mhm.
Because Tuesday was the day that Linden came back. And on that Monday, we thought, I wonder if Linden just does the tickets. Like he just goes in because he comes in at 7, he looks at the ticket and he just does the tickets and gets them taken care of. And hence why we never really see them when we come in because we come in.
later in the day compared to Linden. And lo and behold, when Tuesday Linden comes in and when we get in there, we talk to him and we ask him, hey, in regards to Mondays, do you always come in to a lot of tickets that carry it over from Saturday, Sunday into Monday?
Right.
And he says, yes, they do. And with that, he just, he actually just takes care of them, you know, for the most part. With that said, so we didn't know until Linden was out to figure out, oh, this occurs. So one of the things that we wanted to bring to attention as far as on the weekends, we can't.
We don't know any rhyme or reason as to why they're carrying over, but there's no entries, no next steps, no, nothing occurred for the most part as far as the tickets that carried over from Monday to Tuesday, I mean from Saturday, Sunday into Monday.
That way.
So we just wanted to bring it up to your attention. And with that, we're just going to, you know, obviously monitor the following Monday to see what carries over to that degree. And, but yeah, on your end, if you can monitor, see what you can find out. I mean, I know that on Saturdays and Sundays, you typically aren't working that day either, you know, to that, but
Just FYI, this is something that we noticed, and the only reason why we noticed is because the person that does them was off, you know, so that, so just FYI to that.
So just to get more clarity, so those ticket, because normally if any tickets comes in Saturday, Sunday, right? So who all are in the shift, they should ticket those ticket the same day. There's no point to, unless then there's a callback request or anything, right? They should not forward to next day, even without putting any notes or anything.
Yeah, in my mind, I would think so, because if it was a, let's say, a person that called in on Saturday, then typically that's probably going to be a Saturday, Sunday worker. You know, they work at whatever location that they're at, and with that, they, you know, they're scheduled to work on Saturdays and they called in or they emailed in reporting an issue.
But technically, yeah, I would think in my mind, they were available on that day. Hence, you know, someone on that day should be able to call back, reach them, or however they want to resolve the ticket. They should technically be able to take care of them because it was a weekend person. It wasn't something that came from, you know, Thursday or Friday.
Yeah.
and then carry it over into Saturday, Sunday. It was a ticket that was created Saturday or Sunday, and, you know, with that moved over to Monday. So yeah, you're right. In my mind, that's what it seems like as far as it should be resolvable on that day, because when we looked at the tickets, nothing said, hey, my availability will be Monday.
or anything like that, as far as from the ticket creator, the requester. So yeah, and then we know that some of these tickets were alerts and things like that to that degree as well. But, and obviously some of those, it's dependent in regards to if they can be closed on that day or not, because let's say if an outage occurs and it
carries over into the next day, then I understand in those areas where some stuff could happen in that degree. But I would think, yeah, you're right, majority should be resolvable on that same day. But it looked like, yeah, there was no notes or anything as to why it couldn't be resolved or let alone what
Yeah.
Yeah, so...
I agree with your point because nodes should be there no matter if they are not able to handle it, they're not able to call the customer, right? It's not sharing idle in the new status that the ticket came new as on Saturday and then carry forward on Monday. Or even if you are scheduling those Monday, Tuesday, it should be a valid reason why you're not able to take care of those on the weekends, right?
Mm-hmm.
or might carry forward. Yeah. Well, thank you for highlighting this. I'll probably find some time today to understand this gap. And of course, maybe 1/2 an hour call on weekend, right? Maybe Saturday, 30 minute, connect with the team in a mid-shift. And of course, same for Sunday. So, and you observe this with the regular shift or it's for both Valor and Maxwell.
Correct.
It looked like it was some items were from first shift, some items were from 2nd shift. So it was a mixture.
Or just one.
Present.
I do have one, so this one, I'll take your opinion too, right? So I think we started this earlier, I think one month back. So the shift handover, right? So when, for example, Khan is coming in the later shift, right? So once his shift get over, he, whatever the ticket on the board, right, on that particular shift.
Mhm.
he give the handover to the next person, maybe is coming on that shift, right? So whether if it is a new ticket, if he's not able to handle, so make sure the next person who comes in the shift, right, who can take those ticket if that is a follow up or anything. So Paul comes in the regular 8 to 5, right? So when she start the shift, she should know what.
how many ticket we have on the board, how many going to be the next shift. So if, again, 1%, if one person miss anything, at least the one second person is available who can take those tickets, right?
To avoid this.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, that's pretty much what we do with the shift handover as well. If it's something that we determine, hey, the second shift is possible to take care of this and we weren't able to get to it or the person says, hey, I don't want to be called until 7 o'clock later in the day or whatnot to that degree.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's exactly what the shift handover can assist with. So the next person, you know, the next shift can handle it, if, you know, to that degree.
Right, I think.
No.
And that part, it will be easy for me also to track, right, who is accountable on that, because we have only limited people, right? So I know the Palak given the handover to Kundan, right? So this part is missed from Kundan's side, right? Or maybe this part missed from Palak's side, so that way at least I can get the exact ID and accountable for them.
Mhm.
for the work, whatever they're going to delegate.
Yeah. I mean, if the, let's say, I mean, it could even be a, you know, a small chance that maybe there's a lot more workload than we expected. And if that's the case, I didn't hear anything. If that was, you know, if it was too much, you know, for them to handle or anything like that. So if that's the case, yeah, just let us know and we'll figure it out. You know, obviously have a conversation. You and I come up with a game plan, whatever we got to do. But
Yeah.
No, no, no, we...
Yeah, I didn't hear anything if that was the case, but if it is, yeah, just let us know.
No, no, I agreed with your point. And again, the one more new practice that I've started from this April month where I'm reviewing everyone boards, right? I individually connect with every engineer daily, how many ticket they are on board, how many ticket they are resolving, how many ticket they have closed.
If they close the note hours proper, the communication is made on time. So I'm creating a separate tracker with all the findings. So once the week is completed, whatever the follow-up things I'm going to follow the next week, whatever the improvement they need to make on the ticket side, so they will do it.
So just kind of keep eyes on the ticket volume, how each individual is delivering, if there is any stuck or anything, right? Because we onboarded to new people. So that's why I'm just kind of planning to make sure they are also on track and getting things done on time.
Okay, Roger that.
Yeah.
I think, I think we probably can stick to our agenda, so I'll share my screen then. Let me know if you can see my screen.
Yes.
All right, thank you so again. Welcome to our weekly business review meeting. So this is for the last week. Our agenda remains same, no changes in the agenda. We always check things, how everything going, what are the roadblocks and what we can make better to improve those.
These are a few highlights for the last week. So Vernie successfully onboarded. He has started working on the tickets and is picking chat and everything. And one additional training that we align him for the backup. So in case in the later shift, I think that's what we discuss with Linden.
when the prior service call. So the people who are doing the weekend shift, right? So we're thinking apart from the Helpdesk ticket, the volume is very low. So if anything else they can take care, maybe just only for Saturday, Sunday, they can take care of any other backup or any other ticket. So at least we can utilize them. So I have started.
giving him the training on the backup side. So it should be good on that side. Ticket management that we started to know, reviewing everyone tickets, notes, et cetera, how they are doing. Overall the utilization, I saw the drop in the utilization number. So overall for the team, it was 62%, 62.6 for billable only.
Let's not added the non-billable, just the billable hours. C set, I think the C set report, I'm not sure, like one week I get the report, next week it's auto-generated or someone sent that report manually.
It should all be automated for the most part as far as all the reports that comes in.
So this one I get on March 30th. Yeah, the second one also on March 30th. After March 30th, no reports sent after that.
Really?
So this one, yeah. Prior to that, I used to get weekly, like, and this on 16th, two report normally, the one for, I think it was for ticket closer and the second one was for the C set. So I think after 30th of March, this month I haven't received any report.
It might be a crew thing at this point, because I know that there's two of them, as far as that. One of them was, I had it sent directly to you as far as whenever one came in on every Monday, and I went to go confirm to see if that was still there, which it was.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then, from there, I decided, "Hey, why don't I just create another one? That'll be two that doubles up, that sends it to you same time, same day, with that said, which confirms as far as on the 30th, that's why you received two, and then it also actually sends one to the others as well."
Yeah.
So I think this is probably more of a crew issue is to that degree why it's just stopping whenever it feels like stopping, you know, with that said. I do also know that there's a...
Let me take.
In here and I found that there was an ITBD report that I'm not sure if it gets.
Let me double check.
No, that's not it.
Yeah, so if you can just check that, and I can pull mainly the reports, but yeah, if the automatic is generated at your site, so it'll be good if I get a kind of copy, so make sure we have the correct numbers.
Okay, yeah, I'll take a look.
And...
Do you get one from MSP Bots?
No, no, I think we discussed that, as per London. I should be getting that, but yeah, I haven't get that one even.
The MSP one.
Choptain.
Yeah, because there's one that come, it's a MTS 8 Helpdesk.
Ticket close. It's actually this is the monthly one. That might be why it only sends it to you monthly. I might have to increase the interval on this to see, yeah, to see if I could just get it sent to you weekly. But it also actually has the crew who see sats that pops up in there as well. So I'll see what I can do as far as getting all this sent to you. So I'm just going to hit you up with all these emails and then let you figure it out.
Weekly.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, that'll be good. Thank you. So the last one is, so we already onboarded Abdur successfully. So he have already started picking up many yesterday. He's shadowing Tanya and June and the later shift engineer, but he also started picking up tickets, chat.
I think, I'm not sure, like he was facing some issue with the phone. He probably pinged to Linden, but I think Linden was out, so he was not able to make a phone call on some issue with the password.
I did tell him to reach out to Kelvin, because Kelvin is the headphone person with that said. So if he did that, Kelvin probably would have resolved it.
Gentlemen.
Yeah, sure. Thank you.
Who?
Right, these are the few action trackers in the reporting, which will still keep in tracker MSP bot Abdur onboarding. We have completed the ticket daily border, which I started this recent one, and the last piece that we probably, if you can maybe...
take the rest of the team opinion how we can utilize fully Khan on the weekend shift. And of course Abdur is going to be the another one. Any other task they can take it apart from the Helpdesk ticket. So whatever the time they left.
You know, without the ticket or anything, so they can at least utilize on that particular time.
Mhm.
Sure.
Right, cool. Move for their performance. So this is just put two weeks of data to compare how things are going. So I think Jonath is again on top. 5th to 11th, he delivered 82% overall. Second week, 12th to 18th, 84.2%.
Two, 3%, and it closed forty-two ticket in a second week.
First week, he closed 40. Kundan again, a similar trend, like 45% in the first 5th to 11 and 44 on 12 to 18. So if I check the trending for last two months data that I was checking this morning, so Kundan stands same like 40.
40, 45, 50 max, you know. So as per his capability and skill set, I want to make sure that at least we use him at least 60, 70% on his time, you know. So Maxwell again 74 and second week 78%, Waylor 62 and 63.
Tina 64 and 2nd week 65. Vernie, who recently onboarded, so he made good progress in the first week, right? 40% that he delivered. So he, I asked him to start picking all the call tickets, that anything that comes on his way, so that way he can learn, you know, more about the process, with the...
Clients everything, rather sharing other engineer, so we won't get enough time to get those hands-on experience.
Any question, any of the numbers or that you, any recommendation or anything? I think the two person I think would definitely need your support on that too. Vernie and Abdur. So they are line from my side, right? I'm keeping close eye on them, but yeah, anything that you noticed or anything that you want to do additionally?
For both, so they are ready to take those tasks, you know.
At this time, no. Nothing stands out. I mean, they seem to be picking it up to that degree. Yeah, I don't typically have huge high expectations of them, you know, just being super, you know, Superman, you know, to that degree as far as all that. So right now it seems...
Yeah.
They're progressing okay. And then with that, nothing came up from the, you know, clients or the back end or anybody as far as any issues with them right now. So I think things are going okay.
Good, good to hear that. So I have, I think March month, CSAT has been sent. So we probably get a time, just fill that out. And another thing is, Abdur, we probably, the plan that Amit and we discussed this morning, that for next 13, one or two week, we want to make sure that he is fully aligned.
Once you fully able to take role responsibility, everything what Tina is handling, then probably we can, and you are fully confident that Abdur is fully aligned, so we can probably offer Tina on that particular day then.
Okay.
So that we see there.
Yeah, I think we're aligned. Again, we don't need to wait for a weekly call. If you find anything right, you can reach out anytime, any suggestion for, especially for the two new onboarded people. Yeah, let us know. So if any changes that you'd like to be making their role responsibility or any other technology that you think they can work.
Okay.
because both is going to work on the later shift. So we want to make sure that, you know, we utilize everyone what we have planned for them.
Great, I think we're good. Appreciate your time, Luis, and we'll talk next week then.
Yeah, not a problem. You take care. You have a good weekend.
Yeah, you too. Take care. Bye-bye.